c'est l'heure de notre second débat
débat prospectif aujourd'hui puisqu'il
nous projette à la fin de cette décennie
la France aura-t-elle réussi sa
transition énergétique comment
accompagner les familles et les
entreprises dans l'ère de la sobriété
publique Sénat et partenaire du Conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
accueille demain et mercredi le forum
des scénario avec une question qui est
des centrale les objectifs de baisse de
55% de nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 et de neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 sont-ils tenables on
commence avec ce sujet signé Flora
sauvage elle nous explique ce que
prévoit le gouvernement avec la nouvelle
loi énergie climat regardez
une sécheresse historique des canicules
et des incendies qui s'enchaînent
l'urgence est là en 2050 la France doit
atteindre la neutralité carbone
concrètement cela signifie ne plus
émettre davantage de gaz à effet de
serre qu'on ne peut en absorber mais
pour atteindre cette neutralité carbone
la France doit diviser par 6 ces
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport à 1990 un objectif qui découle
du Green Deal européen comme l'explique
cette expert chargé de recherche sur
l'économie du climat notamment un
objectif intermédiaire de -55% en 2030
donc c'est pour accélérer justement la
trajectoire de réduction des émissions
de gaz à reconfira en fait l'objectif de
neutralité carbone en 2050 et donc ça
c'est un engagement aligné de l'accord
de Paris mais la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre n'est pas assez rapide
pour atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone en 2050 actuellement le secteur
des transports reste le plus émetteur de
CO2 suivi de près par celui du bâtiment
de l'agriculture et de l'industrie
à court terme aujourd'hui on estime très
à 15 milliards d'investissements
supplémentaires nécessaires dans les
secteurs du bâtiment les transports et
la production d'énergie renouvelable le
gouvernement va lancer une vaste
concertation en vue de la nouvelle loi
énergie climat le texte examiné par le
Parlement au premier semestre 2023 doit
définir filière par filière territoire
par territoire les objectifs de baisse
de gaz à effet de serre et les moyens
mis sur la table
et dans ce débat on va essayer de
Serrier d'une certaine façon de lister
les conséquences de cette transition
énergétique sur notre vie quotidienne je
vous présente mes invités Sylvain
boucherand bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
président de la commission de
l'environnement du Conseil économique
social et environnemental et donc nous
sommes partenaires de ces de ce forum
des scénarios qui se tient demain et
après-demain Sandra oubian bonsoir
bienvenue
directrice générale du CREDOC le Centre
de recherche pour l'étude de
l'observation des conditions de vie et
docteur en sociologie j'accueille
également Arnaud gosmand bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes avocat en droit de
l'environnement et Mathieu croissanto
est resté à mes côtés
ce pacte vert là pour l'Europe dont on
dont on parle cet objectif de neutralité
carbone en 2050 et je le disais en dites
moi 50% de démission de gaz à effet de
serre là c'est pour la fin de la
décennie avant de parler des
conséquences pour notre vie quotidienne
Sylvain Boucheron on peut peut-être
commencer par dire qu'on n'a pas le
choix tout simplement
les scientifiques du qui nous le
rappelle quoi même si on médiatise pas
systématiquement ce qu'ils disent dans
leur rapport on n'a pas le choix alors
effectivement on n'a pas le choix et je
crois qu'on est vraiment un moment
charnière de la transition énergétique
on a pris quand même du retard sur les
engagements qui avaient été pris par la
France au niveau européen donc
ça c'est vraiment nécessaire d'accélérer
on n'a pas le choix aussi parce qu'on
commence à sentir les impacts aussi du
changement climatique que ce soit l'été
que l'on a passé entre les vagues de
chaleur d'un côté la sécheresse
chronique quand même toute l'année qui
nous a beaucoup impacté qui impacte à la
fois les citoyens et les citoyens dans
leur vie quotidienne on y reviendra
tiens pas que les entreprises qui
impactent aussi les relations on l'a vu
un peu géopolitique aussi entre les
entre les pays potentiellement et donc
on n'a pas le choix il faut absolument
accélérer on n'a pas le choix mais il y
a plusieurs scénarios pour le faire
alors il y a plusieurs scénarios
effectivement et c'est l'objet donc des
formes des scénarios que l'on organise
demain au Conseil économique social et
environnemental avec l'idée justement de
de travailler sur l'appropriation des
différents possibles différents futurs
possibles concernant la question de
l'énergie donc on va regarder des
scénarios qui ont été faits par exemple
par RTE des scénarios qui ont été faits
par l'ADEME et qui essayent de démontrer
comment est-ce que on peut arriver à
atteindre cet objectif de -40 - 55 %
même aujourd'hui des missions de gaz à
effet de serre en se disant qu'il y a
plusieurs choix ça peut être de
travailler très fortement sous la
sobriété et donc dans les modes de vie
dans l'économie comment est-ce qu'on
réduit les consommations d'énergie les
émissions des effets de serre de
travailler j'allais dire à l'opposé sur
une solide des solutions plutôt
technologique et entre les deux
évidemment il y a un panel de choix des
choix possibles et donc l'idée du forum
que l'on organise c'est justement de
favoriser la propriation par l'ensemble
des concerts et des conseillers du CESU
donc il représente l'ensemble de la
société civile organisée et de faire en
sorte qu'on essaie cette culture commune
finalement sur les questions
énergétiques pour favoriser la propriété
des débats et derrière aussi
d'accompagner les pouvoirs publics sur
ce sujet si je caricature un peu dans
les scénarios dont on parle d'un côté il
y a la décroissance un peu radicale la
sobriété poussée à l'extrême et de
l'autre c'est la technologie va nous
sauver on pourra on pourra continuer de
vivre à peu près de la même façon léger
volontairement caricaturé je vous donne
la parole tout de suite Sandra ou à bien
pour peut-être et vous l'avez évoqué se
poser la question qui est majeure de
l'acceptabilité par par nous
consommateurs citoyen par les Français
en général on l'a vu par exemple avec la
crise gilet jaune c'est d'abord une
réaction à la taxe carbone qui provoque
le mouvement on peut après ça a été
beaucoup plus complexe beaucoup plus
composite mais c'est ça le point de
départ on peut-on lancer la transition
énergétique sans avoir ce précédent en
tête la réponse j'imagine c'est non oui
mais la question de l'acceptabilité en
fait elle se joue pas au moment où on
sort une mesure elle se joue dans un
ensemble de mesures et notamment chez
les gilets jaunes ce qui était beaucoup
ressortis c'était l'idée qu'il y avait
pas d'équité dans les efforts et que on
demandait aux petits à ceux qui devaient
prendre leur voiture pour travailler de
faire des efforts au quotidien et pas
par exemple aux gens qui prenaient
l'avion pour partir en vacances et on le
voit bien sa resurgit d'une autre
manière avec le débat sur les jets
privés mais dans la société française il
y a une attention particulière à la
question des inégalités et donc ça c'est
un élément qui est vraiment essentiel
c'est pas totalement faux il y a
toujours pas de taxes sur le kérosène ça
fait partie des options du système
actuel bref donc ça c'est un premier
élément et puis le deuxième élément
c'est que pour changer les comportements
en fait les individus tout seul n'ont
pas toutes les manettes donc il y a une
partie du chemin qui peut être fait par
les individus par exemple il y a après
65% des déplacements de moins de 5 km
qui sont faits en voiture donc on se dit
que il y en a certains pour aller
chercher la baguette de pain qui
pourrait peut-être être fait en vélo ou
à pied mais il y a aussi une grande
partie des choix qui sont faits par les
ménages qui ne sont pas des choix en
fait parce qu'il y a pas
d'infrastructure de transport parce que
les prix de l'immobilier ont beaucoup
augmenté au cours des 20 dernières
années et donc les gens ont dû
s'installer aussi un petit peu plus loin
des centres-villes parce que la
rénovation de de son logement c'est pas
si simple financièrement
administrativement donc la bonne volonté
la mobilisation des individus ça ne peut
pas reposer que sur sur comment dire la
l'idée que il faut se mettre tous en
mouvement il faut qu'un accompagnement
global pédagogie accompagnement et
justice sociale associé à ces à ces
mesures si je vous entends bien Arnaud
gosma on est en pleine crise énergétique
déclencher notamment évidemment par la
guerre en
Ukraine par l'agression russe mais on
pourrait se dire c'est un une
opportunité ça peut servir et d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être un peu en train de
servir d'accélérateur à la à la
transition énergétique sauf que les
mesures et je suis pas en train de les
remettre en cause pour des millions de
Français elles sont indispensables les
mesures sont des mesures
d'accompagnement budgétaire qui font qui
font en sorte que finalement cette cette
énergie chère on essaie de on s'y
habitue pas vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est le paradoxe de l'époque quoi
un gouvernement qui a le bon discours
lorsqu'il dit c'est la fin de
l'abondance ce qui est vrai attention
pas pour tous il y avait déjà des gens
et manifestement qui vivaient dans la
pénurie mais la société dans son
ensemble vivait dans cet abondance
c'est-à-dire dans la croyance de
ressourcer qu'on pouvait consommer
jusqu'à plus
malheureusement le gouvernement
aujourd'hui et je ne le crédit pas d'un
point de vue politique mais d'un stricte
point de vue des finances publiques
dépensent beaucoup d'argent pour
repousser le problème pour procrastiner
en réalité par exemple à la pompe l'aide
de 18 à 30 centimes d'euros le litre
elle va coûter 4,4 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire de l'argent que l'État va
consacrer à financer des pays pétroliers
pour faire simple et pour l'année
prochaine la première ministre annonce
45 milliards d'euros d'aide diverses non
ciblées manifestement qui vont permettre
que de repousser dans le temps et encore
pas totalement parce qu'elle annonce
aussi quand même une augmentation de
certaines énergies de 15% dès le mois de
janvier donc en fait on est en train de
dépenser des milliards d'euros pour
repousser dans le temps le problème mais
est-ce que c'est possible d'être
efficace sans en ciblant beaucoup plus
j'entends totalement votre argument
c'est vrai que que un possesseur de de
grosses voitures de SUV
thermique puisse toucher la même
resourde que le possesseur d'une petite
Clio enfin c'est absurde on est bien
d'accord mais est-ce qu'on peut faire
autrement et être efficace alors je suis
certain que oui la première des choses
d'abord c'est de dire que ça va bien se
passer et que c'est une c'est un plus
pour nous c'est plus de bonheur c'est
plus de le fait de moins polluer de
moins en moins de envoyer de gaz à effet
de serre de moins consommer de pétrole
etc c'est d'abord un bien-être c'est
d'abord de la santé c'est d'abord des
gens qui se sentent mieux des villes qui
respirent donc d'abord il faut il faut
présenter cet avenir comme positif parce
que bien souvent on a l'impression que
on discutait de sobriété et Mathieu vous
disiez attention à la sobriété punitive
quoi en quelque sorte donc ça déjà il y
a un discours à changer la deuxième
chose aussi c'est que il nous faut un
plan Marshall c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment donné il nous faut un pouvoir
politique et le courage de dire les
choses concrètement quelles sont les
adaptations dont nous avons besoin
qu'est-ce que ça va apporter de positif
et ensuite qu'on puisse avancer oui
aujourd'hui par exemple investir dans
les économies d'énergie ça va créer des
emplois notamment dans un bâtiment dans
un secteur du bâtiment qui en a besoin
pareil pour l'économie circulaire pareil
pour les énergies renouvelables
n'oublions pas que les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui grâce à
l'argent qu'elle ramène dans les caisses
de l'état permettent de ne pas trop
encore souffrir de ce soutien public aux
hydrocarbures donc je veux dire
aujourd'hui oui les solutions sont là
les techniques sont là mais on a
l'impression d'un point politique qui
est un petit peu terrifié effectivement
c'est peut-être le risque gilet jaune un
petit peu peut-être surestimé aussi mais
toute façon on a plus le choix c'est à
dire que dans un an on va pas remettre
45 milliards de haut on a des sciences
publiques ont déjà bien patientes la
situation du covid d'un d'une première
année d'aide aux hydrocarbures on va pas
faire ça pendant 10 ans c'est pas vrai
ou alors on va léguer le problème aux
générations futures avec une dette du
pays qui sera absolument colossale
[Musique]
les bonnets rouges à l'époque le
discours de Jacques Chirac la maison
brûle et on regarde ça fait quelques
années que le gouverneur que je les
exécutifs qui se succèdent reculent
devant un peuple qui se cabre parce
qu'il ne comprend pas forcément les
enjeux soit parce qu'on lui a pas bien
expliqué soit parce qu'on ne lui a vu
expliqué de façon très punitive soit
parce qu'il a d'autres préoccupations
qui sont quand même de se Nour de se
loger moi ce qui me frappe c'est
l'incapacité mais collective je peux en
prendre ma part à se mettre d'accord sur
une sur des questions si centrales que
celle-là et qu'on soit dans le plus dans
les querelles politiques dans dans un
débat à peser il faudrait commencer mais
c'est pas si simple par identifier les
besoins c'est ça pour ensuite pouvoir
définir une politique
efficace définir les besoins et surtout
faire en sorte et ça c'est un point
qu'on porte beaucoup aux saisons qui un
vrai débat national sur l'ensemble de
ces questions énergétiques et qui un
choix qui soit fait par les Françaises
et les Français sur leur avenir
énergétique et qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
qu'on puisse mettre sur la table les
snows sobriété aussi parce que ça fera
partie de la solution qu'on puisse
mettre sur la table aussi l'ensemble du
mix énergétique mais on parle des
énergies renouvelables tout à l'heure on
est très en deçà des engagements que
l'on avait que l'on avait pris il y a
des sujets d'acceptabilité dans les
territoires comment les traite comment
on construit des projets avec les
données citoyens on a fait un avis
là-dessus en mars on aurait mis au
gouvernement justement sur
l'acceptabilité des infrastructures la
transition énergétique il faut que que
que tout le monde se réapproprie son
avenir la question nucléaire également
qui se pose comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour avoir un plan crédible et qui ait
un choix qui soit fait par la nation et
ce qu'on y va est-ce qu'on n'y va pas et
si on y va à quelles conditions est-ce
que l'on est-ce que l'on a on est
capable d'avoir un plan qui répondent au
préoccupations on a fait également un
travail sur les analyses des
controverses liés à la question du
nucléaire
osseuse qui est en avant justement ces
questions entre le financement la
gestion des compétences comment gère la
sûreté la sécurité et donc il faut qu'on
puisse mettre sur la table ensemble de
ces choix là et qu'on puisse débattre
avec tout le monde comprendre les
craintes de certains être aussi dans
cette logique de justice et d'équité
entre entre tout le monde et ceux qui
sont potentiellement les plus démunis et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais
vraiment fait au niveau français et je
pense qu'il est vraiment urgent que l'on
accélère là dessus alors on va détailler
maintenant avec Steve journal les aides
quelques-unes des aides qui sont
proposées aux Français rebonsoir Steve
on commence par le logement à quoi
avons-nous le droit finalement en
matière de logement le grand dispositif
c'est ma primerie rénove elle a été mise
en place dans le cadre du plan
France relance lancé à l'été 2020 c'est
une prime qui permet de financer les
travaux d'isolation de chauffage de
ventilation de votre logement dans la
limite de 20000 euros si vous voulez
rénover votre logement vous pouvez aussi
bénéficier d'un écho prêt à taux zéro il
s'agit d'un prêt qui peut aller jusqu'à
50 000 €, il est accordé sans condition
de ressources tous les logements sont
éligibles et puis autre dispositif mis
en place par l'exécutif c'est la TVA à
5,5% sur les travaux d'amélioration de
la qualité énergétique si vous rénovez
votre logement certains travaux peuvent
bénéficier d'une TVA à taux réduit et
puis aussi les aides les initiatives en
matière de transport oui notamment si
vous voulez changer de voiture pour un
véhicule moins polluant deux dispositifs
ont été reconduits par le gouvernement
la prime à la reconversion et le bonus
écologique le bonus écologique c'est une
prime qui peut aller jusqu'à 6000 euros
pour vous permettre d'acheter un
véhicule électrique ou hydrogène la
prime à la conversion est un peu plus
connue en échange de la mise à la case
vieux véhicules essence ou diesel on
vous aide à acquérir un véhicule moins
polluant cette aide pas aller jusqu'à
5000 euros et puis notez Thomas que ces
dispositifs s'appliquent aussi si vous
souhaitez passer par exemple au vélo la
prime à la conversion peut aller jusqu'à
3000 euros si vous achetez un vélo à
assistance électrique en échange de
votre véhicule et si vous n'avez pas de
voiture à mettre à la casse et bien
grâce au bonus écologique vous pouvez
bénéficier d'une aide qui peut aller
jusqu'à 400 euros pour acheter votre
vélo électrique si vous préférez un vélo
classique vous pouvez demander un chèque
de 150 euros à l'état vous choisissez
Thomas merci beaucoup
Steve c'est une vraie question est-ce
que je passe au vélo il faudrait que je
m'y mette quand même sérieusement je
reviens vers vers vous Sandra va bien
sur le sur ces mesures
incitatives puisque on est sur le levier
incitatif il y a aussi un levier qui
peut être beaucoup plus punitif là on
est sur le levier
incitatif il y a une équation budgétaire
compliquée à mener on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure mais on ne peut pas s'en passer
on ne peut pas se passer de mesures
incitatives et de mesure
d'accompagnement social c'est peut-être
le message le plus important à faire
passer quand on parle de transition
environnementale et de transition
énergétique alors je serai pas
complètement d'accord avec toi parce
qu'en fait il y a beaucoup ce discours
sur l'incitation aujourd'hui sur le fait
que il faut on va on va faire bouger les
gens en leur donnant des incitations la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
fait l'exercice de repartir des besoins
et d'essayer de voir sur quels éléments
on pouvait y avoir des compromis et
d'une certaine manière les citoyens se
sont mis d'accord pour par exemple
décider de s'auto réguler un peu comme
un fumeur qui va se dire attendez moi il
faut vraiment qu'on m'enlève les paquets
de cigarettes autour de moi parce que
sinon je vais pas y arriver et par
exemple ils ont ils avaient proposé que
les SUV les gros véhicules sont
interdits à la vente donc ça peut
paraître un petit peu un peu fort comme
décision en même temps c'était une
décision qui avait été prise après
délibérations avec des citoyens de
différents horizons donc il y a aussi
une possibilité que des mesures fortes
soient prises si elles ont été
finalement elles ont été discutées après
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
elle a aussi des difficultés parce
qu'elle n'était pas prévues pour être
articulées avec le Parlement avec voilà
on savait pas très bien comment ça
allait pouvoir ensuite se constituer
mais a priori cette question la
démocratie participative elle devrait
être portée par le ses eux lors des
prochaines années et s'il y a il peut y
avoir cet articulation avec les
entreprises avec le Parlement il peut y
avoir de la réglementation forte et qui
peut faire changer les comportements on
peut le voir par exemple je sais pas si
vous vous rappelez si vous mettez tout
cela autour de la table je pense quand
il y a eu les changements pour la
cigarette dans les dans les lieux
publics la veille de l'interdiction tout
le monde se disait c'est impossible
personne va l'accepter on va tous et
finalement ça c'est fait et finalement
du jour au lendemain on a changé des
choses donc s'il y a un objectif commun
la santé le bien-être un objectif qui
fait consensus les citoyens sont quand
même capables d'accepter des
des changements et des réglementations
donc l'incitation c'est une partie du
chemin mais il y a beaucoup d'autres
leviers mais je reviens puisqu'on est
sur les transports à Arnaud gosse quand
on habite à 20 km d'une grande ville et
qu'on a très peu de transports en commun
ici il y a pas d'incitation je personne
va abandonner sa voiture vous voyez ce
que je veux dire il y a un principe de
réalité aujourd'hui alors le principe de
réalité c'est d'abord de rappeler comme
vous venez de le faire que la plupart de
notre trajet dans la France entière y
compris rural peuvent être fait
autrement qu'avec une voiture encore une
fois les trajets de moins de 100 km sont
l'essentiel des trajets des Françaises
et des françaises pour ce type de trajet
les transports en commun mais là aussi
font investir dans la sécurité la
propreté la régularité la ponctualité ou
d'autres mobilités douces sont une
solution et aujourd'hui on a
suffisamment d'études pour savoir
pourquoi par exemple des gens comme vous
que ma Hugues hésite à passer au vélo
alors moi qui suis cycliste par exemple
je parle en connaissance de cause c'est
souvent parce que le réseau n'est pas
suffisamment sécurisé les
infrastructures sont pas adaptées où on
se dit peut-être par manque
d'informations qu'en temps lui ça va pas
être possible bref il y a plein de
solutions pour rouler en vélo de manière
tout à fait sécurisée et confortable
mais bien souvent je remarque que mes
interlocuteurs ne le savent pas des des
décennies même des siècles de
civilisations de la voiture quoi c'est
aussi ça il faut ça il faut juste
intégrer cette notion là ça se on
bascule pas d'un claquement de doigts
d'une civilisation à l'autre sauf que
quand vous parlez de bien-être c'est ce
que j'essaie de dire tout à l'heure
pourtant je suis juriste je parle plutôt
de droit de règles en prédiction et
d'obligation mais si je me départiens
tout petit peu de ce rôle de juriste et
que je parle de bien-être sans donner le
son en étant absolument pas parfait et
bien le vélo par exemple c'est un
bien-être pour votre santé ça permet de
purger vos stress de la journée avant de
rencontrer votre famille donc c'est le
vélo qui va prendre et pas à vos enfants
etc etc en termes de santé de poids de
tension artérielle c'est beaucoup mieux
et sans compter l'aspect collectif des
choses aussi on peut rencontrer des
personnes échanger etc ce que je pense
très sincèrement c'est que pour réussir
cette transition écologique on a d'abord
besoin avant même de penser à
l'obligation et à l'incitation etc
informations informations sur
l'étiquette informations sur les travaux
auxquels vous pouvez prétendre lorsque
vous avez un logement et que vous avez
de faible revenu information aussi sur
où est-ce que vous mettez votre argent
en banque parce que ça aussi ça joue
énormément de choisir votre banque de ne
pas financer des banques qui
investissent dans des projets
d'hydrocarbures informations aussi sur
votre alimentation comment faire pour ne
pas dépenser plus tout en consommant des
aliments de meilleure qualité qui
encouragent notre agriculture cette
information là heureusement des médias
comme le vote ils participent mais c'est
vrai que depuis 20 ans je suis surpris
il y a une prise de conscience mais
ensuite comment je fais qu'est-ce que je
dois faire ça reste encore très
lacunaire Sylvain Boucheron sur toujours
sur les les transports
est-ce que c'est forcément la voiture
qu'il faut bannir des centres-villes ou
la voiture thermique parce qu'on a
parfois l'impression d'un combat contre
la voiture en général
en fait je pense que ce qui a été dit à
l'instant par nos gossoit et à prendre
en compte c'est qu'il y a le moyen de
déplacement en lui-même et donc que ce
soit la voiture cher qui a soit
électrique il faut quand même mieux
prendre un vélo plutôt que de prendre
une voiture de toute manière si c'est un
petit déplacement toujours plus
intéressant voire les modes actifs sont
intéressants pour des questions de santé
de nuisances de manière générale donc ça
c'est un point qui est
qui va défendre au-delà de dire pardon
nous interrompre c'est parce qu'on est
en train de dire au niveau français au
niveau européen au constructeur
automobile on est en train de les
pousser à une conversion rapide pour pas
dire forcée vers le tout électrique avec
les conséquences sociales que ce que ça
peut que ça peut avoir les
investissements que ça représente etc
vous voyez ce que je veux dire oui mais
déjà par rapport à la voiture en
elle-même s'il faut la transformer une
voiture qui fait moins des effets de
serre c'est mieux et encore une fois
l'idée c'est d'aller au bout de la
démarche c'est vraiment de pouvoir faire
évoluer ces modes de déplacement le
soutien qui était évoqué dans les dans
les mesures c'est très bien mais il faut
aussi pas uniquement changer sa voiture
son vélo ou son moyen de transport faut
aussi que les infrastructures des me
suivre que tout finalement la société
essaie d'être repensé comment comment on
fait de l'urbanisme des villes en
remettant au coeur justement de la ville
des moyens de déplacement doux ou actifs
et pas forcément basés sur de la
mobilité un peu plus lourde comme comme
la voiture par exemple mais c'est
vraiment une approche un petit peu
globale qu'il faut avoir et c'est vrai
qu'il faut fléchir les investissements
dans ces changements plus structurels et
pas simplement faire des mesures de très
court terme comme le chèque énergie qui
finalement effectivement en retard d'un
petit peu l'action ou le changement
profond qui va être d'investir dans ces
infrastructures plus largement faire des
économies d'énergie je sais pas vous et
moi ça me en tout cas ma génération ça
me rappelle la fin des années 70 en
France on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a
des idées alors pour l'instant on attend
encore la grande campagne de
communication du gouvernement
on entend dans la bouche des ministres
des conseils assez basiques un exemple
parmi tant d'autres on aurait pu en
choisir plein c'est le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Véran
quand on part en week-end ou quand on
part en vacances on débranche un maximum
de prises électriques parce que sinon ça
continue de consommer de l'énergie et
notamment en débranche son wifi on
baisse un peu la clim maintenant que les
températures sont amenées à diminuer
c'est aussi un geste qui fonctionne et
puis bien sûr on éteint les lumières
quand on n'utilise pas les pièces alors
dans le même on est sauvé on est on part
bon c'est pas très sympa de ma part
d'aller choisir cet extrait là mais bon
c'était pas le seul pour l'instant c'est
un peu c'est un peu ce type de
communication qu'on a de la part du
gouvernement va y avoir certainement une
campagne de communication juste avant là
à la fin de peut-être de l'été au début
de l'automne en tout cas il faut que ce
soit avant l'hiver sinon mesdames et
messieurs sera trop tard dans le même
esprit tiens regardez cette lettre
envoyée par l'Opac du Rhône qui gère
donc les logements sociaux chacun doit
prendre sa part nous vous demandons donc
de veiller un usage raisonnable de
l'éclairage de privilégier l'emploi des
ascenseurs au nécessaire personne âgées
handicapées motrices parents avec
poussette sachant que chaque utilisation
d'ascenseur coûte en moyenne 10 centimes
d'euros on apprend une information avec
ça
quand je prends l'ascenseur ça coûte ça
coûte 10 centimes qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire Mathieu je trouve que c'est la
fin de la civilisation du confort pour
beaucoup de gens c'est à dire qu'on va
revenir à des moyens de locomotion ou à
des habitudes qui datent il y a 40 ou 50
ans et c'est peut-être une très bonne
chose de le faire mais il faut
comprendre que les gens ont connu des
voitures qui étaient bringues balance
puis de plus en plus équipés puis
chauffer même avec des sièges chauffants
puis on peut écouter la musique et puis
ça va vite on leur dit ça c'est fini
revenez au vélo comme il y a 50 ans on
dit la lumière la fait l'électricité
c'est génial on pouvait allumer partout
maintenant éteignez-la et coupez-la dans
les heures de grosse tension et de
grosses consommations il y a un côté ne
prenez plus l'ascenseur l'ascenseur on
peut dire que c'était un confort
incroyable on a technologique incroyable
puisque ça permettait de monter des
étages sans se fatiguer maintenant
revenez à pied je pense que c'est pas
passé au vélo mais je prends plus
l'ascenseur
personne n'est parfait mais 10 centimes
je pensais que ça devrait au-delà de la
civilisation de la voiture c'était toute
une civilisation du confort et du coup
et on va retrouver des gestes simples et
ça passera peut-être
et ça se fera du bien à l'organisme et
tout ça mais je pense ça sera compliqué
à faire accepter allez-y et puis je vous
donne la parole juste après c'est vrai
que c'est perçu comme tel mais le
confort c'est aussi 48 000 morts par an
de la pollution de l'air etc je pourrais
citer des chiffres macabre sans compter
les problèmes de surpoids d'absence de
mobilité de nos ados du numérique etc
etc vous savez que les gens ne résonne
pas Macron mais micro c'est à dire il
regarde leur situation il y a des
accidents de censeurs mais je suis quand
même content de comprendre oui les
exemples voitures les gens micros
peuvent consulter leur médecin
généraliste pour leur dire est-ce que
quand je suis au premier étage c'est
vraiment indispensable de prendre
l'ascenseur réponse non sauf bien sûr si
vous êtes handicapé et il faut
absolument protéger ces personnes là
mais pour un grand nombre de personnes
aujourd'hui elles se sont habituées à
une certaine facilité et encore une fois
je suis pas d'honneur de leçons puisque
à titre personnel aussi je commets des
erreurs mais c'est aussi un autre
confort Sandra va bien est-ce qu'il y a
il y a des outils il y a des applis par
exemple pour évaluer le bilan carbone de
ces de ses actions est-ce que ça ça
c'est identifié ça répond à une demande
de la de la société française
aujourd'hui on a fait pas mal d'enquêtes
au credoch là dessus une des difficultés
c'est ce que vous citiez tout à l'heure
c'est la difficulté de savoir finalement
comment est-ce qu'on évalue nos actions
qu'est-ce qui va avoir le plus d'impact
en plus qui est compliqué c'est qu'à
l'impact carbone et il y a l'impact sur
la biodiversité l'impact sur la
pollution de l'air etc donc un individu
normalement constitué en fait ne peut
pas lui tout seul arriver à savoir ce
qu'il faut faire donc toutes les
dispositifs qui permettent d'informer
d'accompagner les ménages aujourd'hui
sont essentiels par exemple sur la
rénovation énergétique il y a
aujourd'hui des conseillers c'est assez
méconnu donc des conseillers qui peuvent
accompagner les gens qui peuvent les
aider aussi à remplir tous les dossiers
parce qu'il y a pas que le problème des
sous il y a aussi le problème finalement
d'arriver à monter son projet et
effectivement aujourd'hui il y a aussi
des applications qui sont développées
après la limite de ça c'est la
multiplication des labels dans le
domaine environnemental on a je crois
une cinquantaine de de la belle variés
par secteur donc bon ça parfois ça
n'aide pas forcément à simplifier
un peu une tension juste par rapport à
ce que vous disiez sur le confort il y a
la notion de confort il y a aussi la
notion de gaspillage et beaucoup de
Français sont sensibles à cette notion
de gaspillage et notamment les
générations les plus anciennes qui ont
cette idée que finalement on va utiliser
des choses sans un vraiment en avoir
besoin et d'une certaine manière en fait
là c'est c'est un peu le passage d'une
société de l'offre où les entreprises
produisent et puis vont chercher à
écouler leur stock à une société de la
demande où on essaye de repartir des
besoins des citoyens et voir ce qui est
utile et ce qui ne l'est pas donc c'est
vrai que c'est un gros changement de
société mais c'est pas comme une perte
de confort c'est aussi peut-être
retrouver un peu finalement un sens de
priorité
pour atteindre ces objectifs de
neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est où on
peut presque parler d'un nouveau modèle
économique qu'il faut qu'il faut
inventer les entreprises jouent un rôle
majeur certaines se mobiliser avec la
convention des entreprises pour le
climat c'est 150 entreprises travailler
pendant un an pour définir finalement
une nouvelle stratégie nouvelle feuille
de route entreprise par entreprise on
est avec Ondine soit avec nous en
visioconférence en duplex qui est membre
de cette convention des entreprises pour
le climat et cofondatrice de My Light
System c'est un je crois pionnier de
l'autoconsommation solaire c'est ça vous
aider les entreprises et les bâtiments à
devenir producteur de leur propre
énergie c'est ça votre business oui
bonsoir à toi à tous oui exactement donc
my light system on a démarré
l'autoconsommation solaire en 2012 à
l'époque personne n'en parlait et on
encourage en fait les bâtiments à passer
d'un bâtiment consommateur d'énergie un
bâtiment producteur d'énergie grâce à
les technologies solaires en effet alors
je viens cette convention cette ce ces
convention des entreprises pour le
climat ça a duré une petite année il y
avait tous les mois un rendez-vous ça a
commencé par des scientifiques du GIEC
qui vous ont vous avez tous pris vous
l'avez raconté une claque climatique et
puis ensuite c'est une feuille de route
ça veut dire quoi on va être très
concret pour votre entreprise qu'est-ce
que vous avez qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de changer
alors très concrètement on pourrait
penser que mon entreprise est plutôt
exemplaire puisqu'on travaille dans les
énergies renouvelables donc on se
sentait plutôt par faisant partie de la
solution et en réalité tout activité
humaine un impact
en calculant notre impact carbone qui
est quand même l'une des premières
étapes pour une entreprise on s'est
rendu compte que notre activité avait en
vendant des panneaux solaires un panneau
solaire nécessite de l'énergie de du
carbone de la matière pour être
construit et comment est-ce que on
compense comment est-ce qu'on régénère
même c'est au-delà de la compensation
parce que aujourd'hui on est beaucoup
dans ces mécanismes de compensation et
les entrepreneurs faisant partie de
cette convention vont au-delà le but
c'est que l'entreprise devienne
contributive pour réparer tout ce que
l'on a utilisé et même piller sur Terre
avec notre modèle économique historique
donc c'est devenir un impact positif
c'est ce que c'est ce que ça veut dire
oui impact positif et même régénératif
donc on répare par exemple nous c'est
d'essayer alors d'avoir des panneaux
solaires qui ont un impact au carbone et
matière parce que c'est pas uniquement
le carbone dont on parle de moins en
moins gourmand et s'assurer que
lorsqu'on les déploie en fait le
bénéfice que l'on apporte d'un point de
vue environnemental en déployant nos
solutions et plus important que le coût
que cela coûte pour les créer ces
solutions restez avec nous j'ai d'autres
questions à vous poser tout à l'heure
Sylvain Boucheron c'est je voulais qu'on
parle aussi des entreprises parce que
c'est souvent au sein des entreprises
que les comportements sont en train de
changer aussi soit parce que il y a des
patrons qui décident d'actionner le
mouvement soit parce que les salariés
eux-mêmes mettent la pression au patron
en cas de dirigeants pour que pour que
ça bouge alors évidemment on va penser à
la nouvelle organisation du terraval
mais c'est aussi ça revient aussi au
transport à l'aide aux transports
mobilité douce c'est un lieu de mutation
économique aujourd'hui c'est un lieu de
mutation économique effectivement pour
l'ensemble des salariés puisque bon le
transport en a parlé mais ça peut être
aussi l'alimentation ça peut être
l'organisation du travail mais c'est
aussi un lieu où on peut essayer
d'imaginer finalement son entreprise qui
est sa mission qu'elle est sa raison
d'être et que demain on continue à avoir
une activité qui peut-être est polluante
ou deviendra inacceptable et il y a des
entreprises d'activité qui ont disparu
et c'est normal parce que le monde
évolue ce qui était acceptable hier ne
les plus forcément aujourd'hui et donc
là il y a un enjeu que je trouve assez
aussi stimulant pour les entreprises les
dirigeantes dirigeants d'entreprise
c'est de se dire comment est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer un modèle économique dans
un monde bas carbone dans un monde qui
est sobre en ressources et là il y a un
champ d'innovation extrêmement large
donc il faut il faut s'en saisir et les
entreprises ont un rôle à jouer aussi
parce que sinon on reste enfermé dans
les modèles d'hier essayer de vendre
plus de produits plus de bien plus de
services dont on sait l'empreinte
écologique que ça génère derrière et
pour ces entreprises c'est aussi des
enjeux de recrutement
recruter des talents avoir effectivement
de sens de raison d'être ou de mission
et d'afficher cette volonté ça devient
de plus en plus compliqué et de
financement vous l'évoquez tout à
l'heure je me tourne vraiment vers
l'avocat maintenant à nos vêtements pour
pour essayer d'évaluer et je reste sur
le cadre des entreprises et la question
du cadre de la loi ou de la cadre
réglementaire à quel point une loi peut
inciter une entreprise à changer j'y
pense par exemple
l'anti gaspillage ou alors les invendus
maintenant les entreprises ne peuvent
plus balancer comme ça librement leurs
invendus au pilon la loi a un impact
elle aussi il y a plusieurs types de
lois la loi fiscale la loi de finances
en réalité elle peut avoir un impact
majeur presque le plus important il est
évident que si vous donnez un signal
prix et que vous dites aux Français
cette consommation là va être taxée
davantage de manière notamment à pouvoir
redistribuer vers les plus modestes je
pense à la taxe carbone qui a été
malheureusement très mal présenté et où
certaines personnes se sont dites il y a
une injustice fiscale face à cette taxe
et l'écologie n'est qu'un prétexte on va
devoir remettre ce chantier à mon avis
sur la table d'ici peu et puis ensuite
il y a des lois type Loi Grenelle ou loi
telle qu'on va en discuter bientôt au
Parlement et dans cette loi le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que ce sont des textes
de plus en plus touffus de plus en plus
complexes où les entreprises qui n'ont
pas forcément toutes des services
juridiques ou des ou des aides de la
part de l'administration pour bien
comprendre ces textes parfois peuvent
être un petit peu perdus c'est vrai que
même pour le spécialiste que je suis je
n'ai aucun mérite je ne fais ça que
depuis 20 ans certains nouveaux textes
me demandent du temps pour pouvoir être
décrypté et comprendre leur sens et leur
porter alors j'imagine pour un nom
juriste ça doit être quelque chose ou
pour un patron ou une patronne de de PME
qui a pas effectivement un service
juridique très très le droit est trop
complexe que la loi est incompréhensible
et bien au final il y a un mouvement de
rejet parfois par rapport à ces textes
d'où l'importance de l'information si
dans notre pays on est des véritablement
les entreprises à se saisir de ce droit
à bien comprendre les droits et les
devoirs par exemple en matière le tri
des déchets dans sa tombe d'entreprises
qui ont pu faire de la résistance je
pense notamment dans le secteur de la
restauration c'est un exemple célèbre et
bien de ce fait là si elle comprenait
mieux l'intérêt de la règle elle
pourrait d'abord l'anticiper cette règle
et ne pas la subir une fois qu'elle a
été votée par le Parlement et puis
ensuite mieux l'appliquer on comprenant
même parfois comment ça peut générer des
parts de marché on parlait de
l'autoconsommation solaire avec Madame
effectivement il y a des entreprises qui
avant même que le droit ne permette
n'encadre cette possibilité pour des
bâtiments de produire leur énergie qui
se sont mises sur ce marché et qui ont
profité de ce droit là le droit devient
une opportunité je rêve que demain dans
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
par exemple on est déconseillé juridique
qui puissent beaucoup plus nombreux
qu'aujourd'hui qui puisse informer les
entreprises sur de l'environnement on
dit une soirée un mot rapide j'imagine
que la crise énergétique que l'on vit
elle vous amène beaucoup de prospects
enfin pardon de futurs clients c'est à
dire que des entreprises ou même des
collectivités qui ne pensaient pas se
lancer vous disent est-ce que vous avez
des solutions pour nous
alors c'est évident que à l'heure
actuelle le téléphone sonne beaucoup
l'autoconsommation solaire en fait
pendant longtemps on n'a pas été
considéré pour les entreprises on l'a
encouragé pour les agriculteurs pour
tout un tas de choses et encore c'est
pas tellement le taux de consommation
qu'on encourageait puisque il y avait un
problème d'équilibre financier et que ce
n'était pas encore tout à fait
particulièrement intéressant pour les
entreprises puisque on était sur 10 ans
de retour sur investissement aujourd'hui
quand vous avez une facture qui a fait x
4 x 5 on est sur 4 à 5 ans de retour sur
investissement pour une entreprise qui
s'équipe bien évidemment il faut faire
des études plus poussées pour pour avoir
un chiffre exact mais là un patron
regarde parce que en 4 ans vous êtes sur
les mêmes temps d'amortissement que une
nouvelle machine dans l'entrepôt et ça
peut vraiment très significativement
impacter votre facture alors je vous
propose maintenant il nous reste moins
de 10 minutes un focus sur un secteur on
est à la fois dans un secteur économique
et puis dans ce qui est notre quotidien
c'est le secteur du tourisme
on va partir en reportage dans une
station de ski à La Plagne comment
s'adapte-t-elle à la transition quelles
conséquence pour nous pour les touristes
c'est reportage de Cécile Sixou
fin de saison d'été à La Plagne la
station est désormais des aires mais
Nicolas provendit le directeur
d'exploitation de chôme pas il commence
à préparer les lieux pour accueillir les
skieurs cet hiver on fait face de la
levatière qui a un télésiège débrayable
6 places qui a été construit l'an
dernier par nos équipes l'équipées de ce
qu'on appelle un moteur électrique lent
qui permet par rapport à ce qu'on
construisait avant finalement de
supprimer toute une chaîne mécanique le
rendement est donc bien meilleur et
exploitation équivalente on consomme un
petit peu moins d'électricité un
télésiège tout neuf moins consommateur
d'énergie cette année pour le directeur
d'exploitation de la station chaque
économie compte car les prix de
l'électricité explosent et risque de lui
coûter très cher toute entreprise on a
surtout besoin de visibilité de pouvoir
pour nous tout simplement établir nos
budgets dans le but bien sûr de
fonctionner pour le client qui vont
venir nous voir cet hiver et ce qu'on a
besoin c'est de visibilité et d'un prix
au mégawatt qui nous permettent tout
simplement de fonctionner correctement
ça va Nicolas ouais très bien le maire
de La Plagne également président de
l'Association des Maires des stations de
haute montagne a rencontré le
gouvernement et demander explicitement
un bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie pour
les stations de ski
l'État français ne va pas pouvoir
laisser les choses en tel état en tout
cas en tel difficulté puisqu'on est une
industrie l'industrie du ski et comme
toute l'industrie en France à un moment
donné il y a beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois
qui sont générés par cette activité et
si cet emploi est en difficulté c'est
des centaines de milliers de chômeurs on
l'a vu et cela ce serait juste pas
possible donc on reste positif les
stations vont ouvrir et le gouvernement
va trouver une solution pour qu'on ne
soit pas impacté en attendant Nicolas
prouvendi a prévu de réduire la
consommation d'énergie dans la station
de 10 à 20%, il compte notamment baisser
les températures dans les locaux
raisonner la production de neige de
culture mais surtout ralentir les
télésièges à plus long terme il aussi
pour plus d'autonomie énergétique sur la
station donc là c'est les panneaux
solaires qu'on les premiers panneaux
solaires qu'on a installé on a pour
projet des sites en installer sur le
toit aussi on est en train de regarder
parce qu'on a une belle surface une
belle exposition pour d'éclairage ou du
chauffage en journée ça peut fonctionner
très bien on est on est sur des choses
qui sont tout à fait envisageables avec
un principe d'autoconsommation tout
simplement
mais ça reste sur des usages plus
domestiques impossible de compter sur
les panneaux solaires peut producteurs
et dépendant de la météo pour produire
l'énergie nécessaire au remontées
mécaniques avec son directeur technique
Nikola provendis développe d'autres
ressources l'objectif c'est trouver les
énergies de grande valve qui permettent
de diminuer notre notre consommation
d'énergie là on a des bons espoirs c'est
sur l'hydroélectrique donc l'objectif
c'est d'utiliser nos canalisations de
neige de culture
au lieu de pomper de l'eau c'est plutôt
de turbinello qui coule et là dans les
potentiels qu'on a on aurait 20% de
notre la consommation annuelle en
production des dents électricité 20% de
la consommation produite en
hydroélectricité mais pas pour tout de
suite Nicolas provendit estime qu'elle
ne pourront pas être mise en place avant
5 ans
Sandra va bien c'est combien de Français
qui partent au ski en moyenne c'est quoi
entre 7 et 8% des Français qui partent à
la montagne en hiver au ski en fait il y
a déjà beaucoup de gens qui font pas du
ski parce que il faut être un petit peu
sportif pas être trop âgé c'est un petit
peu dangereux donc finalement et puis
évidemment c'est aussi très très cher
donc on est vraiment sur une portion
congrue de de la population après vous
disiez un plateau mais il y a aussi
toutes l'économie qui tourne autour donc
c'est vrai mais cette économie on avait
fait une étude au crédit qui a plus de
15 ans je crois maintenant sur le fait
qu'il pouvait y avoir aussi un autre
désir de vacances d'hiver avec d'autres
types d'activité qui était pas
nécessairement des sports des sports
d'hiver donc bon on peut aussi avoir une
économie touristique qui puisse vivre
avec peut-être d'autres activités
de disparition comment comment vous
réagissez en voyant ça je me dis que le
changement climatique est installé
depuis bien longtemps on en perçoit
d'autant plus
vous inquiétez pas sans les conséquences
aujourd'hui que ça va pas aller en
s'améliorant et que nécessairement le
manteau neigeux est en train de
disparaître en réalité on a déjà
beaucoup de reportages sur des stations
de ski de basse altitude qui sont
obligés de fermer avec un patrimoine
industriel dont on ne sait pas toujours
que faire donc très clairement oui
aujourd'hui anticiper c'est se dire
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire d'autre comme
activité à la montagne je crois pas du
tout que l'économie va disparaître mais
parce que ça reste un paradis mais elle
va peut-être se démocratiser elle va
peut-être effectivement se diversifier
il y a déjà aujourd'hui une station de
ski puis qui propose d'autres sports y
compris l'hiver le trait etc donc je
suis je suis pas inquiet je compte sur
l'ingéniosité des gens mais c'est vrai
que se dire que le téléski va
fonctionner plus lentement c'est
peut-être bien un très très court terme
mais au final s'il y a pas de neige il y
a pas de neige et la neige de culture
n'est pas une solution à grande échelle
pour sauver cette économie du ski il va
falloir faire autre chose vous auriez
pas jusqu'à comparer aux mines du Nord
ou de l'Est de la France dans les années
80 c'est pas la même c'est pas la même
mécanique qui est en train de se mettre
en place parce qu'on peut on peut
peut-être anticiper on peut peut-être ne
pas laisser les gens sur le carreau on
peut peut-être mieux les former on peut
peut-être écouter tous les jeunes gens
qui sont aujourd'hui des écoles et
universités qui veulent faire autre
chose non il faut pas il faut pas
représenter ça comme un avenir cyniste
ou il y avait pas il y avait pas de
bonheur or le pétrole et ce type de
vacances non et pourtant tu sais si
j'adore le ski on va bien se passer si
on s'y met tous il y a une prise de
conscience une anticipation par les
politiques ok ça fait beaucoup de
conditions mais je suis assez optimiste
peut-être un mot de conclusion Sylvain
Boucheron ce que ce que moi je retiens
un débat comme comme celui-là c'est ce
sentiment qu'il faut inventer des
solutions qui sont des solutions de
lentées de long terme et des choix à
faire qui nous engagent pour des
décennies mais dans l'urgence cette
équation qui est très compliqué
notamment pour les politiques oui très
compliqué alors après c'est vrai que ça
fait des années que on en parle et qu'on
aurait eu du temps pour se préparer je
pense que des idées il y en a beaucoup
la question c'est comment les accélère
comment on les accompagne et comment les
accompagne dans différentes dimensions
ça peut être des soutiens financiers un
petit peu parlé et la dimension sociale
comment on fait évoluer l'emploi
également comme on fait évoluer les
compétences que le but c'est de laisser
personne sur le carreau et le pire qui
pourrait arriver c'est de maintenir des
activités polluantes sous prétexte que
ça génère de l'emploi ils vont on peut
pas rester dans dans des ambiguïtés
on ouvre une centrale à charbon alors ça
va pas durer éternellement mais c'est
c'est sur les autres sur les autres
aspects et je pense qu'il y a deux
piliers sur lesquels il va falloir
vraiment mobiliser l'ensemble des
politiques publiques la question de la
sobriété comment on économise de
l'énergie des ressources et encore une
fois cette étonnant l'exemple sur l'eau
les entreprises qui qui avait commencé à
travailler sur les économies d'eau à
changer un peu leur modèle être moins
dépendant de l'eau bah elles sont sans
les sorties que les autres et l'autre
voler c'est s'adapter comment on fait
dans un monde qui change pour imaginer
les modèles de demain qu'est-ce qui
demain sera une aspiration pour les
citoyens et les citoyens qui sera pas
une contrainte le vélo électrique je
pense que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
agréable que le vélo il y a 50 ans donc
on n'est pas du tout dans un retour en
arrière absolument pas et donc de dire
comment on imagine justement cette cet
avenir qui soit désirable pour tout le
monde et on laisse en laissant personne
de côté merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat et
donc ce forum des scénarios qui se tient
au CESE demain et après-demain et Public
Sénat et partenaire de cette événement
voilà votre prochain rendez-vous
notamment rendez-vous politique dans la
matinale Oriane mansini vous voyez son
portrait s'afficher reçoit
François-Xavier Bellamy député européen
ce sera demain à 8h du matin si je ne me
trompe belle soirée à tous